what do you normally look for like what
are the
uh qualities that you look in you know
a woman if you're going to spend any
time with a long time bit long-term
long-term basis beyond just like a plate
status or somebody that you know becomes
an fwb in your life and
you know you may call her a girlfriend
you may not whatever maybe
um it goes in any number of directions
but what do you typically look for
in women when you're trying to vet them
for you know hey listen you know you're
an athlete you made a lot of money
you're a good-looking guy you're tall
like you take off
every box that chicks are looking for
generally speaking so what do you look
for
yeah it's it's real you know i gotta be
honest it's really hard this day and age
for
for guys like me because i believe
marriage and a lot you know
most women know what i've done in the
past so it's kind of hard to know what
they're really after
so you really really got to be careful
um
for me i think one of the most important
things for me is
does she have a strong family background
does she have
a good father um to me that's that's
really huge does she have a good
mother's
i mean was she growing up in a great
family environment
um because i feel like women that don't
that i've dated their train wrecks they
typically are
dads beat them or abuse them or left
them mom's a drug out of you
do you see a lot of daddy issues in
southern california i mean
i would say in the last five years i've
been divorced
sixty percent of women i've taken out
have had daddy issues and yeah i found
the same thing here in toronto
dude it's like you know you sit down
it's like you know they hate their
father they won't talk to their father
you know like any any one of those you
know their father abused their mother
their father ran off and
when they were a kid it's like well hold
on a sec sweetheart like you sure about
that you sure maybe mom didn't push him
out of the house like right did he
really run off on you like
have you have you kind of dug into this
one right
yeah just to see if they've done some
work right like that's one of the things
that i look for
yeah 1 000 and you know there's got to
be a level of confidence there that she
has
and not not boss [ __ ] confidence i
can't stand that [ __ ]
boss girl hashtag boss girl buddy come
on sign up for that man
boss [ __ ] don't you want to come home
to a disagreeable woman after a hard
day's work bro
i want dinner on the table i want you to
have your feminine energy at home i'll
bring my masculine energy home and then
we can really have some fun
but when a woman is trying to outdo the
man masculinity-wise and trying to bring
home the bacon
it's just it doesn't work and i feel
like the gender roles in today's society
have been reversed
now don't get me wrong like rich i
believe in marriage 1920s 1930s
when that [ __ ] meant something women
loved being at home they took pride in
being home and raising the kids while
the man went out and
provided for the family they stayed for
any and all reasons back then dude there
was really no divorce
absolutely and now we live in a society
now where
women are like being empowered by
radical feminists to go out there and
work
men are getting kicked in the balls to
be staying home and
what's happening is you have all these
like uh you know like i said the roles
are reversing
and it's easy for a woman now
to just bolt in a marriage
if things get hard they don't want to
work because all they have to do is say
you know what
i don't really want to work on this this
guy's rich as [ __ ]
and then their friends get in their ears
and they're thinking well you know what
honey if he's treating you like [ __ ] you
deserve better take half this [ __ ] go
away
and they're instant millionaires so i
have i have a little story in my book
about that i know you read it but it's
like
starbucks and this chick was basically
told by your best friend like
you know i don't have i can take half a
[ __ ] and not have to put up with this
dumb ass too
yeah right yeah it was like and until
it's why would you sign up for that
yeah i mean like until that changes in
the court system
unfortunately it's not going to any time
we're never going to see it
higher and higher in in our lifetime i
don't see that changing i don't like
it's going to take women getting
together ripping off the pink [ __ ] hats
throwing them away burning them and
saying you know what ladies um
let's go march on capitol hill for you
know for the guys today you know let's
change the marriage law so they're not
hostile towards fathers right like
that's what it's gonna take well i don't
i don't necessarily i do blame them
but i blame more of the white knight
vader cup [ __ ] that are like
the males well they reinforce it yeah
the the third they're the guys there at
the rallies for these feminists
holding the signs and that gives these
women a sense of like oh guys are with
us those aren't men
yeah those are not men those are they
don't want to bang those guys
no no not at all not at all yeah so
it's it's it's definitely like you talk
about a high value man and i say this to
my friends all the time
i s and i tell people i like listen
there is no reason for a high value man
in today's society to ever ever get
married
never yeah i mean it's unfortunate but
that's the reality of it right i mean if
you've got half a brain in your head
you have everything to lose and nothing
to gain yeah especially i mean if you
want kids have kids if you want
like for me i want a life partner i
would love a life party at some point
right right now i'm kind of enjoying my
freedom and if she comes along
great that's awesome but we have to
compliment each other right
um she she's got to have some kind of
brains on her
she's got to have some kind of dreams
for herself
to where she's not latching on to me 24
7 texting me 10 times a day
i need space i'm an independent guy and
i don't need you around
all the time so that's hard to find too
rich like there's so many insecure women
out there that think just because i
don't text her back in the next two
hours
right holy [ __ ] it's like a [ __ ]
crate it's it's unbelievable like i'm
sorry i was working out they have a
complete spasm right like a big
big meltdown yeah it's like
that's that's a red flag right there let
me ask you this question so
i got a couple of notes here that i
dropped in the description so let me run
um this is what i think high value men
should
seek as far as qualities in women
femininity awareness
and awareness in the sense where i don't
expect women to take ownership
for many of the things that they do i
mean
some guys want women to take ownership
for being hypergamous right and cheating
on them it's like well dude
like i talked to this guy a couple of
weeks ago huff who was a young man he
was about 20 23 24
and you know he was going out uh
drinking with his stepbrother
and his stepbrother got drunk passed out
on the floor puked all over himself
and his wife started chatting up this
other guy and he's like you know i just
can't trust women it's like dude
okay put yourself in her shoes for a sec
right you know if you're going to be a
passed out loser drunk on the floor and
this guy becomes you know
her better option it doesn't matter that
she's married hypergamy does not [ __ ]
care
right so i'm talking about some level of
awareness not ownership i'm talking
about
some level of awareness as far as the
masculine feminine roles
and taking a little bit of ownership and
putting some investment into herself
on any areas in her past that need to be
dealt with guys are really really good
at
wanting to do the work not all will
execute on it but i wish that
more men that are on the top shelf
looking for women would look for women
with some level of awareness
the other thing that i said uh following
that up was ownership
maturity maturity in the sense that they
don't have a hissy fit you know what i'm
talking about like you don't text her
back within you know her two-hour time
frame
in her head and then she has a complete
meltdown over you
that's like a level of maturity that you
expect out of some women by
a certain age right i mean like a 12
year old i expect to throw a hissy
you know from time to time so there's
maturity class
i mean it speaks for self she doesn't
show up with like a
big you know jail tab on her shoulder
when you take her out to a
classy event she's wearing an evening
dress you know what i'm talking about
beauty obviously you know fertility cues
boobs hips you know bum uh a compliment
to a man's life
and essentially i watched a coach red
pill video the other day and i haven't
watched very many of his stuff
lately but it popped in my feed and he
was talking about what to look for
in um women and he basically boiled it
down to a cheerleader and i have to
agree with him
um i think that you want a woman that is
your cheerleader
you know you know she's got your back so
those are the main ones that i thought
that
men should see is there anything there
that you look for you know beyond that
or is there anything that you would
cross off that list
well you know i think
no i love i love all that but i think
you know like
i'll take my marriage for example i was
married 11 years and when i when i had
the baseball gear on
i was making 10 million a year i'm
coming home every night
my my wife at the time would i come home
at 11 o'clock at night and she'd be in
lingerie
just fresh out of the shower wet ready
to just [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of me every
night right
i was the alpha i was the guy and i knew
it and i felt it i was confident
and i knew when i came home she was
going to be that way and she
i could i knew she wanted me you could
just see dude you're making 10 million
dollars a year you're a jacked athlete
and you've probably got rings at this
point or on your way to getting rings
right right
right yeah and it's it's just i knew
that was going to happen so
obviously as a man your confidence level
is huge you know
you and you feel like a man and she's
treating you like one
i was being treated like one and that
made me feel [ __ ] great i was excited
to go home
and then i retired and then i made the
mistake i wish i had your book of corn
okay you know honey i'm done i'm retired
why don't you go live your dreams i'm
gonna go
every day take the kids to school i'll
go grocery
shopping i'll do the laundry i just want
you to work on you and so essentially i
was doing all these things every day
for months on end so they actually tried
to better ties yourself by making
yourself less so she could become more
yeah yeah i baited myself and that's why
i'm so passionate about not
to other men not to do that yeah and i
started feeling
less of a man i started feeling like a
caged [ __ ] lion bro
and i started getting depressed i didn't
i i started resenting her because i felt
less of a man
and it really wasn't her fault i had
done it to myself
and i could see her energy towards me
kind of back away i got to the point
where i'm starting to have to beg
for sex yeah what the [ __ ] is going on
here
that's when the clock is ticking down to
the end of that relationship she started
getting into fitness
really big time oh yeah and then she
started going out with her friends until
four in the morning i'm like
ah we gotta have a ladies night aubry
gotta have a ladies and gentlemen bro
what the [ __ ] is going on and before you
know it i'm like
pissed off and i'm tired of begging for
sex we get a big fight i move out
we get separated for a while eventually
leads to a divorce
and i look back at it now i'm like [ __ ]
i did that to myself yeah right
i didn't i didn't put her what would you
talk about frame
yeah right i i i put this ridiculous
frame around myself
as a [ __ ] at home doing women's work
that's not attractive to a female
and as i look back at now i realize my
mistake and that's why
i'm so passionate now about what you
guys are doing and what i'm i dabble a
little bit in what you guys do
but not like you guys do and that's why
i kind of open up this new company alpha
america
american apparel because i want guys to
know
you can never stop being alpha because
the minute you stop
you're no longer desired by a woman
you